our next guest accounted for 50 passing
touchdowns last year for the ohio state
university buckeyes and he is destined
to be only the third first round
quarterback ever to come out of ohio
state he's dwayne haskins he joins us
now dwayne how are you buddy
good good how are you
i'm doing great hey did you have more
touchdowns last year or helmet stickers
i think i have more helmet stickers
actually
and like how many helmet stickers did
you have
i had my helmet full i it was so full i
couldn't even get any more stickers on
it by like my northwestern game it was
full up
what do you get them for how what's the
formula for getting a buckeye on your
helmet
buckeye leaves you get back out leave
for making a big play scoring touchdown
getting a sack in the fumble
uh first downs uh stuff like that
when do you guys find out how many
buckeyes you get from the prior game
uh monday not monday uh tuesday's
practice after tuesday practice we get
it do you have an idea of how many
you're going to get or is it you know
the final ruling comes from the coaching
staff
they come from the coaching staff but
usually i get about 10 plus a game so i
get a lot of buckeye leads
now what kind of competition is there
among the players as to who gets the
most stickers
it was me and bosa before he got hurt as
far as who can get the most every week
and then after that i was meeting terry
so those are two guys i was going back
and forth throughout the season did you
end up with the most
yeah i had the most at the end of the
season yeah as well
hey um
i i i watched your highlights it took a
long time to watch highlights of every
touchdown pass from last year if i told
you a year ago you were gonna have that
kind of production when it comes to
touchdowns in your first full year and
only four years as a starter what would
your reaction have been
i believe you definitely i thought
that uh before the season actually we
talked about the records at ohio state
and uh i wanted to go break that but i
don't know i was gonna beat the big ten
records so that's pretty cool
draft night you're gonna be bowling are
you actually gonna bowl or is it just
the party is at the bowling alley
well i'm gonna be bowling for sure
yeah what kind of bowling game do you
have how many how many buckeye lease
would you get for your bowling game
uh not a lot
i'm not a good bowler
uh pretty decent uh you know i'll get
the job done uh so i can do enough to
help out
what's your best game
best game uh
i don't feel like football of course but
uh
pretty good at man best your highest
score your highest score oh high score
oh highest score
i said like a good day it was like 160
165 that was my part of my best hey you
know you know we we we would we would
actually we would actually have a good
competition that may be the only thing
i'd have a chance at competing with you
in because that's about that's my best
if i if i could just get in that zone
you know you know that feeling when
you're just in that zone and it happens
rarely for me but
yeah beyond that i heard you mention
madden you play a lot of madden
uh that's hard that's why i learned
football growing up it's bad
yep now i
guys have told me in the past that
they'll spend a little time before the
draft creating themselves and putting
themselves in different uniforms to see
how it looks has dwayne haskins done
that yet
i've done it as a kid i've not done it
recently no i should actually try that
when i get home after this let's go try
that
when when you did it as a kid what
uniform looked the best
uh a lot of them all of them look great
i don't i don't know which one looks
best uh i always had the visor and the
towel and the spats and you know i just
i've tried every team actually growing
up just because uh i would play
franchise mode and i'll just just draft
a whole bunch of players and that was
fun for me
well a lot of uniforms have changed so
you do need to update it and get a new
look because nike got involved and and
it seems like everybody's got a new
uniform one team that hasn't gotten a
new uniform yet the new york giants
you've been linked to them and you seem
to embrace that talk of possibly playing
for the giants
yeah definitely uh being a jersey kid
uh possibly being a new york giant would
be a dream come true for me and uh you
know be able to be a part of that
process to even be considered by new
york this is crazy for sure i'm
definitely excited about possibly being
the dhi
one thing the giants have talked openly
about is what they call the kansas city
model a reference to when the chiefs
drafted patrick mahomes they had alex
smith for a full year mahomes learned
behind him and then started to play the
following year what would your
preference be to play right away as a
rookie or to have that year where you
could sit and study someone else learn
the ropes and then be ready to go in
your second season
yeah whenever whatever i go to i just be
ready to play whether that's year one or
year two and um i don't have a
preference whether that's playing right
away or or playing a year two or year
three i just want to be the best
quarterback i can't even be for that
franchise and passion for he's
definitely did a great job learning i
learned from jt my first two years at
ohio state so it isn't foreign nature
for me so i mean i'll be comfortable
with you more
best thing about draft week for you is
the visits are over the questions are
over you can just focus on what's to
come what's the question you got the
most during that pre-draft process from
teams
the question i got most is if i was
ready to make that jump to be a nfl
quarterback only having one year in
college
that's probably the question i get asked
the most throughout the process
what was the answer you gave
just that um i felt like as each game
went on during the season i got better i
felt like i got more comfortable in my
offense and i had a great season so i
feel like my best friend falls in front
of me and i'm only gonna get better
what kind of criticism have you heard in
the questions you get from teams about
your game and they may not be direct
about it but you get a feel
for you know maybe they're poking at
something or or bringing something up
about a weakness that they think needs
to be addressed
every team that i meet with they always
ask me about
my experience and whether that would be
a handicap for me or whether that'll be
used for me
to get better at um every team that i
every team that i meet with we watch
film and i don't get questions asked
about weaknesses much so we just asked
what we what we see on the field and uh
what what um what i see and protections
and coverages and things like that so
they all they all know me you know you
know i have a lot of room to grow so uh
they definitely i've shown a lot of
interest all people have that with
hey duane how close of a question was it
for you to decide to leave ohio state
and enter the draft
uh it was hard decision for sure for me
to be able to make that final decision
of leaving
always wanted to be the nfl but a house
is a place that i've grown
up loving and always wanted to be a part
of and talk to my parents about it the
opportunity was too great for me to not
leave for the nfl and it was a hard
decision to make but i prayed about it
and the best that was probably the best
solution for me at the time
how much does it bug you to hear
questions about your mobility because i
saw some plays against northwestern that
suggest a high degree of escape ability
and agility in the pocket when you hear
criticisms of your ability to move with
the ball what do you say
i say watch a northwestern game watch
the maryland game
you know my game is to win from the
pocket but i'm not an oak tree by any
means i can move if i need to i wore a
knee brace during the season which i
hated because it made me feel very uh
limited in my mobility but i won't be
wearing one in the nfl so i mean the
biggest thing for me is this whatever it
takes to win is what i want to do to win
you know whether that's uh making a play
or throwing from the other pocket i can
do it at high level
the knee brace was that a precautionary
thing you had an injury you were trying
to rehab or something i mean because a
lot of quarterbacks will wear that knee
brace even if they're perfectly healthy
as as a as a safety precaution
walk me through why you wore it and why
you're not going to be wearing it
i wore it as a healthy for safety for
health precautions because i didn't want
to get hurt coach dave make sure i wore
it but then i was in practice i walked
through the t-shirts i wore the embrace
all the time just because uh he didn't
want me to get her during the season
but you've already made the decision
going forward you're going to shed that
knee brace at the next level
yeah i'm going to shut it i'll probably
wear something smaller or something i'll
just uh be able to
help first first injury but i won't be
wearing the big bulky one anymore for
sure
what's your best throw
my best friend i would say my d ball i
think like uh i think i know that that's
probably my favorite throw to throw
whether that's a deep post or a deep
goal route and i just feel like i have a
great understanding of how fast the
guy's running where the defensive back
is where the ball needs to land at and i
just the the time we get this patient
and the placement of the ball something
i have a lot of fun with with other
people
let me flip it over give me a throw
you're working on in an effort to get
better at it at the next level
the one you're working on the most
yeah not necessarily a a particular
throw the biggest thing i work on both
is that being able to move off a spot
and still throw accurately so that's
what i'm working on the most as far as
moving to my left
i feel like i did a great job to the
season moving to my right and still
throwing right but uh being able to move
to my left for the throw across my body
something i work on the most
do you feel your accuracy improve when
you're on the move
i feel like i feel great on the run and
uh definitely to the right to my left
but uh either you know where i feel like
i can throw from anywhere on the field
so i probably myself will be able to
throw the road and throw in the pocket
is there a quarterback you've modeled
your game after
uh steven's mayor warren boone
a lot of other quarterbacks in the
following brady
uh peyton manning drew brees a lot of
guys
i've heard you say that you're not
necessarily competing with any other
quarterbacks in this draft class but my
assessment is if kyler murray had picked
baseball or had decided to stay at
oklahoma you'd be the guy that we'd be
talking about as a potential first
overall pick does it bug you that you're
not getting that kind of buzz the kind
of buzz that kyle murray is getting as
the draft approaches
no i'm here i'll need the hype i'm all
about substance and i don't really care
about me being first overall every
second overall i just want to be in a
position where team wants me and i want
to be there i want a whole bunch of
football games and you know the big
thing about me is that i'm going to put
my out of work and uh just looking
forward to opportunity to be a part of
nfl
you know you initially decided to go to
the university of maryland you changed
your mind and went to ohio state and i
asked all that not to dig up the past
but the difference now is you don't get
to pick do you wish it's some level you
got to pick where you were going to go
next
uh sure but you know that's the fun
thing about the draft if someone used to
pick you that's exciting about it but uh
i wouldn't change anything for the world
i just want to you know be able to get
this line over with and get back to work
do you have a little list in your back
pocket of one two three four teams maybe
you're hoping are the ones that call you
up
well the team has shown interest to me
and teams that i i think are gonna pick
me so
i'll have a short list or a piece of
paper in my pocket of who i want i just
want to get drafted that's all i care
about
who has shown the most interest in
dwayne haskins
a lot of teams um a lot of raiders the
redskins
broncos dolphins and the giants
those are the teams that show the most
interest in me
is it more important to you to be
drafted as high as possible or to land
in the perfect spot where your career is
going to thrive
perfect spot where robot charisma
thrives a lot of my former household
teammates said that excited about how
early in the end it's about where you
land and i just want to be a position
where i can be a franchise quarterback
for that team for the years to come and
be a part of a team that you know i feel
like i can leave a legacy with and you
know whatever team takes people i'm
gonna do the best i can do to leave that
legacy
you recently put this on twitter don't
overthink it trust me what did you mean
by that was that football related
uh possibly i forgot why i said that
honestly but
uh
definitely uh this this process is a lot
of outside noise a lot of uh second
guessing and uh you know if you want
somebody who's gonna help you with
football games i won't overthink it i'll
just just trust it hey you know it's
good advice for thursday night when
you're lining up the bowl right
yeah yeah definitely this is trust that
trust that bowl man
all right tell us what you have going on
with old spice
yeah so i'm doing a partnership with old
spice and uh we're doing a great thing
with the
with the moisturizing collection and
i'll do for all new fresher collection
with real benefits and uh ingredients
and uh to be able to have uh
moisturizing with shea butter and real
lavender and body wash and you can pick
this up at walmart it's been a great
partnership for me and being able to be
a part of those places
love the love of their their product and
definitely something i look forward to
using the rest of my career
hey you know something i mentioned
earlier dwayne and let you run you will
be only the third quarterback in ohio
state history to be a first rounder and
it has been a long time 30-plus years
since the last first round quarterback
out of ohio state does that have extra
meaning for you and for the program
definitely uh i'll be the first
quarterback picking the big ten in the
first round since 1995 with kerry
collins so that's just crazy to me i
feel like oh he has a great great amount
of talent at every position and i'm
looking forward to being that guy to be
picked in the first round and be a great
quarterback in nfl
and leave that legacy for ohio state so
looking forward to being a quarterback
in nfl most definitely well duane i'll
tell you we think you have all the tools
and we're rooting for you
congratulations on everything you've
accomplished in your one year as a
starter with ohio state we're looking
forward to 10 15 or more years as a
starter at the nfl level and we wish you
all the best on thursday and beyond
thank you for having me appreciate it i
look forward to it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports